Da bin ich wieder wie versprochen. Naja, was heißt versprochen?
Es kann ja nicht sein, dass man sich darauf verlassen kann, wenn ich sowas sage, aber wie versprochen, ich bin heute wieder da
Und zwar heute mal zur Abwechslung
Erstmal meinen Hörzertritt aufsetzen. Ah, was habe ich denn hier am Kopf?
So
Mit einem massiv high IQ thema, aber dazu muss ich erst mal warten, bis das Stream richtig angelaufen ist
Denn es vier leute am start, jetzt sind es zehn leute. Twitch hat es noch nicht kapiert bzw. noch kein Notifications verschickt
Jetzt ist es am start
Ganz ein high IQ Subscription Box Camper sind am start oder wie nennt man das auf Twitch?
Auf Twitch sind es ja keine Subscription Box Camper, sondern
Channel Profile Camper
Geco Schwede, moin
The virus ist am start, physics, it's gamer
21 ganz wichtig
nicht 20, nicht 22
Oh Leute, heute machen wir mal was. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert
Kanäle nur Volks Camper, genau. Ja, man hat ja auch Inbox, Inbox Camper könnte das
Notification, wie heißt das, wie heißt das bei
Twitch eigentlich
Benachrichtigungen, ich dachte es heißt Inbox
Hatte, wait a minute, hatte Twitch nicht auch mal eine PN-Funktion?
Nee, die gibt es immer noch, gibt immer noch dieses Chat, diesen, diesen, diesen Privatchat, aber den benutzt ja keiner
Leute, heute machen wir mal was spannendes, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert
Wir versuchen
von einer Android App
Traffic mitzuschneiden
die das nicht will
Hintergrund ist folgende, ihr wisst ja, dass ich einen Addon programmiere, beziehungsweise programmiert habe, oder ja am maintainen bin
Für Fiat Elektroautos, wobei es mittlerweile nicht nur Fiat unterstützt, sondern auch Jeeps
Ram Trucks, wo ich gar nicht wusste, dass es das gibt, das ist hier so ein Ami Ding
Teilweise Alfa Romeo Auto und
Dodge, das ist auch so ein Ami Ding, braucht ja keiner
Genau, und es gibt ein Feature, was ich
wahnsinnig gerne einbauen würde in dieses Addon, ich zeige es euch mal kurz
Ich habe noch nicht rausbekommen, wie es funktioniert, es gibt nämlich hier den Fiat Champ
Ja, das ist das Addon, seit gestern, seit gestern Version 3 am Start
Und der kann alles mögliche von, von Uconnect, beziehungsweise vom, vom Auto auslesen, ja, was ich jetzt hier
Uconnect, beziehungsweise vom, vom Auto auslesen, ja, Batterieladung, wieviel Minuten das noch dauert zu laden, Kilometerzähler, Reifen
Aua, was habe ich denn am Kopf hier, warte mal kurz
Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube ich habe mich gekratzt
Ich habe mich irgendwie gekratzt hinten am Kopf und genau da ist das Headset, ist natürlich optimal
Zapp ist volljährig geworden, 18, 18 Jahre, Pock, nice, Dankeschön, the flow, the game
Genau, und es gibt ein Feature, was es nicht auslesen kann, nämlich Eco-Reports
Eco-Reports gibt es bei Fiat, da stehen so Sachen drinnen, wie
Ja, einmal, wie umweltschonend man gefahren ist, das ist jetzt nicht so das, was mich großartig interessiert
Was ich viel interessanter finde, ist, du kannst tatsächlich genau sehen, wie lang
Und wie, also wie lang eine Fahrt war von der Strecke und wie lang die gedauert hat, das heißt, du hast ein automatisches Fahrten-Log
In diesem Auto drin und das kann man nur über die App auslesen, nicht über die Webseite, das ist ein App, ein App-only-Feature
Allerdings geht das ganz normal über die Web-Requests an die Fiat-AP, wie alles andere auch
Ich habe Offstream, weil sowas darf man Onstream immer von aus nicht machen
Gut, wo kein Kläger ist, wie heißt das, wo kein Kläger ist, da kein Richter, oder so
Naja, wahrscheinlich hätte es keinen interessiert, ob ich das Onstream mache oder nicht, aber ich habe die App decompiled Onstream
Habe mir das Ganze angeguckt, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das ist der abartigste Source-Code, den ich je gesehen habe
Aber gut, das ist halt die Compiler-Source-Code
Und ich habe es nicht genau richtig gecheckt, wie diese ECO-AP aufgerufen wird
Deswegen ist mein Plan für heute, wir installieren uns einen Android-Emulator
Auf meinem Fire-Tablet funktioniert es leider nicht, das habe ich schon ausprobiert, das ist zu alt, die unterstützen nur Android 6 und neuer
Wir installieren uns einen Android-Emulator und dann müssen wir irgendwie dem Android ein eigenes Zertifikat unterschieben, was wir generieren
Und dann müssen wir dem Android sagen, sie sollen ein Proxy verwenden von uns
Und auf dem Proxy captchern wir dann den Traffic von der Fiat-App
Wie gesagt, ich werde mich hier nicht einloggen, ich werde bloß gucken, ob es dann funktioniert, weil ich nicht wirklich noch irgendwas leaken oder irgendwas zeigen darf
Wir gucken dann, ob der Login-Bildschirm mitgecaptchert werden kann
Zumindest will ich den HTTPS-Traffic von dieser App mitschneiden, sodass ich mitschneiden kann, wie die Requests für die ECO-Reports sind
Dass ich die ECO-Reports in meinen Addon einbauen kann, in meinen Home Assistant Addon
Ja, glaube ich hat man verstanden
Ja, entweder das, entweder Mitten oder Burp, eins von beidem
Aber bevor wir anfangen, wir müssen uns natürlich jetzt mal wieder das Hackerman-Linux installieren, wir installieren uns mal eine Runde Kali-Linux
Weil, wenn schon, wenn schon dann richtig
Keine halben Sachen
Das geht nur mit Kali-Linux, ich meine es geht theoretisch mit jedem x-beliebigen anderen Linux auch, es würde sogar theoretisch mit Windows gehen
Aber, echte Hackermans verwenden Kali-Linux, deswegen verwenden wir heute auch Kali-Linux
Mein Android will ja immer noch nicht meine Custom-DNS-Resolution auf eine LAN-IP vom DNS-Server akzeptieren
Ja, guck mal, also ich habe schon ein bisschen im Vorfeld gelesen, es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten, man kann Android Studio installieren
Oder man kann Genymotion oder wie das heißt installieren
Zumindest muss man anscheinend das System routen, weil man ansonsten keine Route-Zertifikate installieren kann seit Android 6
Das heißt wir versuchen es erstmal mit einem uralten Android 6, dem das Zertifikat unterzuschieben
Mal gucken ob die App da drauf überhaupt läuft
Das wäre das einfachste, müssen wir mal gucken
Ja, schauen wir mal
Aber das Allerwichtigste jetzt erstmal, was Kali.org ist es glaubt
Eine Penetration-Testing-Distribution
Visual-Images, Torrent-Kekel, Alter
Kein Torrent
Oh, nicht so schnell, aber die Minuten haben wir Zeit
Android Studio ist plaud, aber da ist ein guter Emulator dabei
Ich hoffe die App gibt es für x86, weil wenn es die App nicht für x86 gibt, angenommen die gibt es bloß für ARM Tablets
Dann wird das Emulieren echt abfuck langsam
Hat jemand schon mal ein ARM Android Handy auf einem x86 PC emuliert?
Das ist nicht schön, ARM Emulation ist nicht schön
Warum hat einfach Kali in einem Container?
Geht auch
Aber, dann habe ich ja nicht die GUI und die ganzen Sachen
Ne, ne, das wird jetzt in die VM gepackt
Das ist übel Slam, ja ich weiß ich habe auch schon versucht Sachen crossfilen zu machen
Für ARM mit QEMU
Das ist so extrem langsam
Da schläft es wirklich ein bei
Ja, das waren wir heute
Waren wir kurz hier vor allem auch vorbei
Sekunde Leute, wo habe ich jetzt den Kram runtergeladen?
Äh, nein
Da
Ja
Ok, also
Oh
APKs liegt
Die habe ich selbstverständlich
Alle selbst von meinem Handy extrahiert
Die APKs, die habe ich nirgendswo runtergeladen, das ist logisch
So
Was ist denn das, ein 7zip Archiv
Ok, gehen wir mal nach
E double Punkt slash VMs
Und dann legen wir da irgendwie mal Kali Linux an hier
Und dann kopieren wir das mal rein
Und dann packen wir es mal, gucken was da rauskommt
Da sollte jetzt ein VM Image rauskommen
Ne, wahrscheinlich kommt eine fertige VM raus, die ich dann einfach noch anklicken kann und dann ist gut
Äh
Extract Files
Yes
Ja, dann extracte mal
APKs laden ist nicht verwerflich
Ne, ist es auch nicht
Pff
Es ist überhaupt kein Ding eigentlich
Naja, es sei denn
Man lädt APKs, die normalerweise was kosten
Da muss man sich schon drüber streiten, ob das verwerflich ist, wenn man quasi das Payment umgeht
So, Kali Linux ist entpackt
Äh, hier ist die VM
Warum sind denn so 30.000 Disks
Ok, Kali Linux, VM-Wer
Äh, wir upgraden erstmal die VM-Hardware
Auf das neueste, was wir zu bieten haben
Äh, ja das ändern wir mal
Finish
Close
4 CPUs
Müsste gehen, ich hab ne 6 Core
Wir virtualisieren auf jeden Fall
Die Virtualisierung
Klingt irgendwie bescheuert
Aber wir müssen die Virtualisierung virtualisieren
Weil ansonsten kann ich keine nested-Virtualisierung in der VM machen
Und ich geh immer ganz stark davon aus, für die Emulation des ganzen Zeugs brauchen wir nested-Virtualisierung
Ich weiß, dass wir es brauchen
Ich hab im Vorfeld schon gebraucht, man braucht nested-Virtualisierung
Ähm
Number of Processors 2-2
Ne, ne, ne
Einer und vier Kerne
Und mehr RAM
Auf jeden Fall mehr RAM
Wie viel RAM geben wir dem Ding?
Emulationsteuisch und so
Ach ja, gib ihm 16G, easy
Alles klar
Ähm
So, jetzt verschieben wir das Ding mal auf den zweiten Desktop
Und schmeißen es mal an
Und gucken mal
Natürlich, echte Hackerman-Distribution, was sonst
Was findet ein Uni-Professor?
Das können wir auch irgendwann mal gucken, aber nicht jetzt
Allein schon, dass man sich
Uni-Professor geht noch irgendwie
Da gibt es ja auch welche
Die beschäftigen sich überhaupt nicht mit den Schülern
Beziehungsweise den Studenten, die machen einfach ihr Ding
Ja, damit kann ich mich anfreunden
Aber Lehrer wäre echt was, der hätte nicht sowas von keinem Bock gekauft
Ehe für kein Geld der Welt würde ich Lehrer werden
Weiß nicht, was mit dem Sebaro los ist
Aber
Irgendwie
Gibt ja zum Glück gibt es ja Leute
Die wollen das machen
So, jetzt wollen wir kurz hier den Chat aufmachen
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Okay, Lehrer sein mag vielleicht nett sein
Aber mit Schülern sich auseinandersetzen müssen
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht nett
Eltern
Ja Eltern sind nervig und Schüler sind nervig
Beides, beides, beides ist nervig
Ganz im Ernst
Ich hätte da überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Schüler, Alter gerade so
Im Jugendlichen, Kinder schreien rum
Und Jugendliche facken einen ab
Ich hab gestern wieder die Steinheimer
Assi-Kinder gesehen, wo ich beim Rewe war
Ich war beim Rewe
Und davor haben irgendwelche
Steinheimer Jugendlichen rumgegammelt
Alter, was für Assis in dem Alter sind
Die waren keine Ahnung, 13, 14, 15
Oder so
Die sind direkt auf dem Weg zum
Offenbacher Hauptbahnhof
Vom Rewe gammeln, na klar
Was sonst
So
Dann gucken wir mal
Eine Runde Kali-Linux
Die Fall ist glaube ich Kali-Kali
Wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe
Ja, korrekt
Massive Hackerman Distribution am Start
Also was wir brauchen ist wahrscheinlich
Mitten oder Burp
Eins und Bein
Au, Leute ich hab
Nervig mit dem Headset heute
Wie setze ich denn das am besten auf
Ich hab mich irgendwie gekratzt am Kopf
Und jetzt ist es genau dort
Wo mein Headset sitzt, mal gucken ob ich ein paar Haaren drüber kriege
Oder so
Genau wo mein Headset sitzt
Au, das ist ja richtig beschissen
Alter
Genau wo das Headset sitzt
Ah, ich kann es glaube ich so machen
Ich glaube so gehts
So ist es ok
Ich bin da geschoben
Ok
Wie fangen wir denn da jetzt am besten an
Ich würd sagen wir fangen mal mit was simplem an
Nämlich Android Studio installieren
Wie installiert man überhaupt Android Studio
Und warum
Was Kali in
Warum hat Kali US keyboard
MonkaS, wo ich gleich mal umstelle
Layout
Was ist denn das, ist das XFCE
German
German no dead keys
Ist das XFCE hier was man da sieht
Mit Fiddler
Fiddler hab ich noch nie verwendet
Ok, ist das jetzt
Deutsch Tastatur, jawoll
Bisschen größer machen das ganze
Aha, eine ZSH, ist schon mal nice
Ok
Haben wir hier sowas, jawoll
So dass wir das dann auch ordentlich bedienen können
Gut, wie fangen wir denn da jetzt am besten an
Lasst mal kurz überlegen
Gibt es
Wir machen mal ein Update
Ups, ja ja
Wir machen, ich kann ja tippen
Wir machen erstmal ein Update
Ich glaube das schadet auch nichts
Was haben wir hier? FTP, Hallifax
RWT Aachen
Macht einen langsam Eindruck
Eindruck der Hallifax
Machst du Faxen
1200 Packages
Gib ihm
Na ja, lassen wir ihn erstmal updaten
GG Eats, wir lassen ihn erstmal kurz updaten
Aha
Ok
Doch in Kanada
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht warum das Ding so heißt
Anscheinend ist
Anscheinend ist es in Aachen
Eckerchamp Distro, ja so siehts aus
Studentenwohnheim in Aachen
Ach, der Server steht neben einem Wohnheim
Über eine DSL Leitung
Deswegen ist das so langsam
Das wird schon echt
Echt der Uni Server mit dicker Anbindung sein
Aber bisschen schneller könnte es doch sein
Guck mal hier, so 7 MBit
Das ist ja wirklich nicht viel
Das reicht
Man sieht es geht vorwärts, aber ein bisschen schneller
Könnte es schon sein
Hat Kali standardmäßig eigentlich
Irgendwelche Tor Browser
Was jetzt?
Die Form ist abgekackt
Ah ne doch nicht, ok alles gut
Alles gut, easy, easy
Was war das jetzt schon wieder
Wäre Blue Stacks keine Option
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Ich benutze normalerweise keine
Android Emulation
Ich probier es mal mit dem Android Studio
Weil es der offizielle ist
Und ich hoffe, dass es damit am besten funktioniert
Wenn nicht, nehmen wir Gini
Gini Mode, Gini Motion
Weil ich hab gelesen
Gini Motion ist already rooted
Was praktisch ist
Also wir werden folgendes probieren
Wir probieren es mit Android 6
Und wenn es mit Android 6 nicht funktioniert
Weil Android 6
Ist das mit dem Zertifikat am einfachsten
Wenn es mit Android 6
Und dem offiziellen Emu nicht funktioniert
Dann probieren wir es
Mit Gini Motion
Also das wird
Das Ganze wird dann folgendermaßen aussehen
Massive Pain Skills
Kann man das ein bisschen dicker machen
Also
Wir haben hier
Sekunde
Pepofet
Wir haben hier unsere
Unsere
KaliVM
Da drinnen haben wir dann
Ein Android Emu
Die nächste Birne
Oh, ein Android Emu
Und
Ich merke gerade, dass mein Bild
Überhaupt nicht funktioniert
Weil die KaliVM ist ja viel größer
Pass mal auf, hier Massive Pain
Drawing Skills
Alter, kann man ja doch nicht zugucken hier
Besser
So, die muss nämlich fetter sein
Die KaliVM
Die KaliVM ist so
Die ist Massive Pepo
Pepo Breit
So, wir haben die Android
Also das ist die KaliVM
Wir haben den Android Emulator
Dann haben wir hier
Einen Proxy
Proxy
Und ich hoffe, dass ich es hinkriege
Dass die Android Vm da drüber geht
So, und hier haben wir dann
Hier haben wir dann quasi das Netzwerkzeug
Das Netzwerkzeug
Von der Vm
Und das geht dann raus hier in
Massive Wolke Internet
So
So sollte das
Sein von der Idee her
Und hier kann ich dann mitschneiden
Da, da kann ich mitschneiden
Was für Laptops benutzt du eigentlich
Und was hältst du von Apple Silicon
Ich benutze gar keinen Laptop
Ach du weißt nicht, was ich auf der Arbeit habe
Da habe ich jetzt ein Surface Book
Ja, ist es auch
Aber es muss ja nicht schnell sein
Für ein paar Requests
Ja, ups
Hallo, yes
Ok, er ist beim Installieren
Er hat schon alles runtergeladen, ging ja schnell
Auf was
Basieren Kali ist das Debian
Also ich weiß, dass es Abt hat
Das kann ich mir noch nicht erinnern
Was basiert denn das
Cut
Etc Debian Release
Ne, Debian Rolling
Hätte er noch zu bieten
Was für eine Debian Version
Basiert denn das
Was ich mit dem
Android Emulator machen will
Also ich erzähle es jetzt nochmal
Weil ich habe es am Anfang erzählt, aber es sind
Jetzt erst die Leute dabei gekommen
Ich habe ein Home Assistant
Also ich habe ein Home Assistant
Addon programmiert, was Sachen
Von Autos abfragt
Es gibt aber so ein paar Sachen, die kann die
Offizielle App, wo ich noch nicht rausbekommen habe
Was die offizielle App da eigentlich
Genau an Requests macht
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
Wir installieren uns einfach mal
Die offizielle App in einem Android Emulator
Und gucken, dass ich die
Requests von der offiziellen App mitschneiden kann
Das ist nicht so einfach
Weil seit ganz schön vielen
Android Versionen
Erlaubt
Android eigentlich keine User
Installierten Zertifikate mehr, die das gesamte
System
Den das gesamte System vertraut
Das ist mittlerweile unter Android so, du kannst zwar
Zertifikate installieren
Und du kannst das auch für deinen Browser und sowas verwenden
Aber Apps müssen das explizit
Kennzeichnen, dass sie User
Zertifikate akzeptieren und das
Machen die meist logischerweise nicht
Das heißt, entweder nehmen wir eine ganz alte
Android Version, bleibt eigentlich plus Android 6
übrig, weil das die kleinste Version
Ist, die die Fiat App unterstützt
Oder wir nehmen eine
Neuere Android Version und dann müssen wir dem
Irgendwie, da müssen wir das Ding irgendwie routen
Und dem als Route Zertifikat
Unser Proxy Zertifikat
Unterschieben und dann hoffen, dass es
Funktioniert. Guck mal
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich
Das ist eine andere Taktik
Da wird das APK ausgepackt
Das Zertifikat ausgetauscht
Und wieder eingepackt
Das gibt's auch
Wir modifizieren heute nicht das APK
Sondern
Wir gucken, dass wir das
So hinbekommen
Das machen wir heute nicht
Wir probieren das heute mit dem Emulator und dem Proxy
Wenn das Zeug irgendwann mal
Update
Mal gucken, ich hab das noch nicht gemacht
Also ich hatte bis vor
Keine Ahnung, 4-5 Stunden
Keine Ahnung davon
Dann kennst du dich ja aus
Und wenn es nicht funktioniert, kannst du mir sagen, woran es liegt
Wie viele Tabs möchtest du aufhaben
Ich hab noch mehr Tabs auf, ich hab da und da noch Tabs auf
Da hab ich noch viel zu wenige Tabs auf
Und ich kann da noch die andere vor allem aufmachen
Aber ein bisschen mehr Tabs
Ich mein ganz im Ernst
Irgendwie muss der RAM voll gemacht werden
Guck mal
So die Hälfte an RAM voll
Verschenktes Geld
Meine Güte
Kali, update mal
Ganzer Python Crab
Weg damit
Das mag ich auch an Arch Linux
Ehrlich Leute
Pacman und die ganzen Updates, gerade die Downloads
Mit parallelem Download
Und den Updates, die sind einfach super geschwind
Hättest du mal mehr Cores
Und RAM in der VM sehen, in dem Fall bringt es ja nichts rein
Aber im Dezember Leute
Ich bin immer noch
Ich hab immer noch den Plan
Neuer Rechner kommt im Dezember
9900K
64G RAM
Viele SSDs
Jetzt wird mich irgendwas zwischen
4.000 und 5.000 Euro kosten
Massive Geld ausgeben
Ne 10K wird es nicht kosten
Wir geben ihn nicht aus
4.500 oder so kostet das glaube
DDR5, klar
Ich meine jetzt
Wo ich so viele Sponderings gemacht habe
Jetzt rollt die Kohle
Jetzt kann ich auch noch einen Rechner kaufen
Nicht so, dass ich da im Geld schwimmen würde
Durch
Aber ganz im Ernst
Wer durch diese Placements wirklich sich
Jibaden lässt
Da irgendwie
Pay to Win zu machen, dem ist echt nicht zu helfen
Wenn du bezahlt wirst
Du verdienst sogar noch mehr als ich
Ach so Matchmasters
Ja dann ist doch ganz einfach
Ich geb dir einen 10 Euro Pinata Code
Was hältst du davon?
Leute wollt ihr
Wollt ihr einen 10 Euro Pinata Gutschein für Matchmasters?
Ich hab gehört
Ich hab in meinem letzten Video einen Link
Mit einem 10 Euro Gutschein für Pinata
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wofür man das braucht
Ehrlich gesagt
Brauchen tut man es wahrscheinlich gar nicht
Amazing, danke schön für den Sub
Ist das sowas wie Tinder?
Das klingt bisschen so
Ist aber ein
Peggle Clone
So ein Edelstein
Matchgame Ding
Nichts was ich spielen würde normalerweise
Aber
Easy Money, Easy Life
Ey wir haben die Updates
Geschafft Reboot
PC Speaker an MonkaS
Nice Plan
So solltest du das machen
Steuern bezahlen dann in Insi Modus
Wobei eigentlich müsstest du in Insi Modus vor den Steuern
Weil ansonsten lohnt der Insi Modus ja nicht
Erstmal Insi Modus machen
So
Haben wir es geschafft
Da sind wir Leute
Das Terminal soll mal ordentliche
Schriftgröße behalten
Gut lasst mal Leute
Ich muss mal in mich gehen
Also was brauchen wir jetzt
Android Studio
Brauchen wir jetzt
Gibt's das
Jaja
Gibt's das unter
Abinstall Android
Android
SDK
Ist
Android SDK gleich
Android Studio
Find ich nicht oder
Nee okay da muss man es wahrscheinlich
Downloaden
Ähm
Android
Download wo gibt's denn das
Ich hab das
Legit noch nie von Hand installiert
Download
Android Studio ja Pog
Auf geht's
Genau das will ich haben
40 MB die Sekunde
Saugen
Was geht das
Ist das dabei
Können wir Search machen
Über JetBrains hab ich es tatsächlich schon installiert
Aber ich will mir kein JetBrains Toolkit installieren
Um das
Rauf zu hauen
So Download ist durch
Gehen wir mal hier CD
Downloads
Xfz
Android Studio
Ein Snap
Igitt
Ich hoffe Kali hat steil mich kein Snap drauf
Android Studio ist
Extracted
Android Studio
Und jetzt wahrscheinlich bin
Und dann Studio
Do not import settings
Okay
Do not send
Next
Standard
Android Emulator
Ich will nicht nur den Emulator haben
Den restlichen Crampel brauch ich ja gar nicht
Next
Accept
Accept alles wird alles
Accepted Finish
ADB und sowas ist hier bestimmt drauf
Ehe
Aber das installieren die
Das installieren die wahrscheinlich mit
Erstmal Android Studio drauf hauen
Dann dem Emulator
Wir nehmen mal irgendeinen
Nee wir bringen ja kein neues Android
Ich brauch wirklich ein altes
Also es gibt die Möglichkeit
Das hab ich im Vorfeld gelesen
Entweder man nimmt ein ganz altes Android
Also Android 6 als kleinster gemeinsamer Nenner
Da kann man nämlich noch Zertifikate installieren
Die dann systemweit gelten
Oder
Wenn das nichts bringt
Dann müssen wir ein neues Android nehmen
Was ist das für ein Betriebssystem
Kali Linux
Nur für echte Hackerman
Eigentlich macht es überhaupt keinen Sinn
Wir brauchen dafür nicht zwangsläufig Kali Linux
Eigentlich geht das unter jede explodierende
Linux Distribution
Aber warum nicht
Hast du schon Kali aus sowas gebrauchbare
Skippmeta Packages
Nee
Android
Ehe gibt's nichts
Die AVDs sind eigentlich schon routet
Ja wirklich
Easy
Finish
Probier mal gleich aus
More Actions
Virtual Device Manager
Was haben wir hier
Sollen wir das einfach mal probieren zu starten
Android
Tiramisu
Ist das das neueste
Ok kommen wir starten
Was ist da im Hintergrund los
Emulator is running
Ja gehen wir nicht auf den Keks
Ich weiß dass das nicht optimal ist
Ich muss mal
Kurz meine
APKs rein
Kopieren
Oh Mann bin ich blöd
Das bringt mir so natürlich nichts
Ich muss schon File Browser aufmachen
Wollen wir mal in Downloads oder so
Ei das geht oder was
Direkt drag und drop geht nicht
So haben wir meine APKs
Hallo gibt es einen Registry Key
Womit ich unterbinden kann
Dass der Browserverlauf in Edge nicht gelöscht werden kann
Nicht gelöscht werden
Ich musste Google befragen
Es gibt ja für fast alles Registry Keys
Macht das was
Guck mal es bewegt sich
Unser Fake Handy booted
Mal gucken
Wie die Auslastung ist
Also ich hab von wen aus keine Ahnung
Also da bist du echt beim Falschen
Ich hab keinen Schimmer
Vielleicht weiß es der Chat
Oh
Boah da brauche ich aber viel CPU
Guck mal unser Handy booted
Ok
ADB
Haben wir nicht
Ok muss ich tatsächlich installieren
Ok wir haben ein Handy am Start
Wo sind denn die Buttons
Leute ich bin zu dumm Enter zu bedienen
Wie kommt man da jetzt in Starter rein
Hier
Ok war schonmal keine gute Idee
What
Alter
Was macht mein Handy da
Von unten nach oben
Ok
Ah
So und ihr sagt das Zeug
Irgendjemand hat gesagt
Das wäre schon gerooted
ADB root
Nee
Shell oder
Und jetzt
Sudo
Ok
Sollte das nicht eigentlich gehen
Oh das geht
Ich bin root
Easy
Ok das ist einfach
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht
Dass das so einfach ist
Ok
Ok die Dinger sind schon rooted
Das ist natürlich relativ praktisch
Guck mal ob
Chrome startet oder irgendwie so was da drauf
Nein nein wir wollen Chrome nicht besser machen
Nein wir wollen auch Passworts
nicht anmachen
Wer ist der Song im Background
Kann ich dir sagen
Muss selbst nachgucken
Super Mario RPG
Beware the forest of mushrooms
Nee nee nee
So rum
Zu viel Pilze
Pilzstelz
So sieht aber eigentlich in Chrome nicht aus
Oder
Meint ihr wir müssen einfach
Nur noch eine Weile warten und dann geht Chrome auf
Vielleicht ist es einfach nur langsam wie sonst was
Hat deine vm volle
Ram Auslastung
Nee die hat 5
Von 15G
Ja die Anzeige ist bisschen pepega
Aber CPU
Auslastung hat sie ganz gut
Alter was ist mit dem Browser los
Keck wait
Keck keck keck
Also
Irgendwie habe ich meine Zweifel
Dass Chrome jetzt noch aufgeht
Ich meine der ist
Der ist ziemlich am CPU fressen aber
Ansonsten
Hat die App Third pinning weißt du das schon
Keine Ahnung
Ok das wird nichts
Ist das jetzt zu
Oh
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht was passiert hier
Alter der Android der Emu ist ja
Abartig langsam
Ok
Google.de
.com
Also das funktioniert nicht richtig oder
Wie mache ich denn Apps zu
So? Ne
Wie
Wie schließt man Apps
Okay, wir machen mal, wir installieren mal, wir installieren mal die App, ob das theoretisch
funktioniert.
Äh, ADB war Push, oder?
Push?
Und dann direkt, nehmen wir mal hier den DuckDuckGo Browser zum Beispiel, ne war nicht Push,
war es einfach Install, ahja, Install, der DuckDuckGo Browser, vielleicht geht der ja,
wenn Chrome dann richtig funktioniert.
Yes, schickt mir alles, ich will alle Notifications haben, let's do it, äh nein eigentlich will
ich den, den nicht als Default Browser setzen, okay, google.de, boah ist das schnell, Boar's
Jam, ey, ist ja auch schon beschämend, dass der DuckDuckGo Browser funktioniert, aber
Chrome funktioniert nicht, geil oder, KegWade, der Chrome hat keinen Bock, lull, okay, dann
machen wir mal was anderes, Download, äh, die Fiat App, draufhauen, erst mal gucken,
dass da drauf alles läuft überhaupt, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
Willkommen zu dem heutigen Projekt, ich will gucken, was die App macht, dass ich das in
meinen Home Assistant Addon einbauen kann, so Install ist halt geklappt, okay, aha, aha,
aha, guck mal da, guck mal da, eine Fiat App, sehr schön, nice, die App startet da drauf
schon mal, so, jetzt müssen wir uns das ganze mit dem Proxy angucken, also, wir haben jetzt
die Auswahl, Mitten oder Burp, also mit, also ich kann euch mal zeigen, wie das bei alten
Android Versionen ging, dann hat man das hier aufgemacht, hat einen Browser gestartet,
irgendwie, wie komme ich da jetzt wieder raus, hat einen Browser gestartet, komm, wir ziehen
uns das, boah, ist das laggy, Alter, meine Güte, äh, ziehen uns das dahin, Fiat App
ziehen wir, ziehen wir auch dahin, ja, hat man das gestartet, das ist ein Proxy, das ist
der Mittenproxy, das ist ein Webinterface dafür, man geht mal auf Mitten.it, oder Punkt
IT, äh, und dann sehe ich, dass ich kein Proxy gesetzt habe, ah ja, ich hab kein Proxy gesetzt,
wie setzt man, das ist das nächste, wie setzt man unter Android eigentlich ein Proxy, Manage,
ok, ne, so schonmal nicht, Internet, T-Mobile, Keckel, Alter, Turn Off, Hä, ah ja, Musik ist
ein bisschen laut, aber das ist nur der Track, das ist viel besser, ähm, wie, wie setzt
man da jetzt Proxy-Settings, Proxy, was, Bearbeiten, ach hier, Hä, Advanced Options, Alter, wie
versteckt, wie versteckt ist denn das, Mensch, ok, äh, was haben wir für ne IP, also, 122.168.65.151.80.80,
save, so jetzt sollte man eigentlich schon was sehen im Proxy, wenn sich da was tut,
vielleicht noch speichern vorher, ähm, so, und jetzt muss ich das Zertifikat installieren,
wie, wie refrescht, wie refrescht man eine Seite, so, ah, guck mal da, da tut sich schon
was, ähm, und jetzt brauch ich ein Android Zertifikat, ah, cert, warte, ich krieg grad
was geschrieben, ich bin grad Stream-Son, ich muss mal kurz antworten, jo, ich bin
gerade, ähm, Stream-Son, so, jetzt hab ich nicht hingeguckt, was jetzt passiert, hat
das jetzt runtergeladen, oder, jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich nicht hingeguckt, ist, hat das,
hat das jetzt runtergeladen, oder was, ah, da ist das Zertifikat, ok, oh, wow, wow,
wow, wow, wow, install CA Zertifikat in Settings, this server must be installed in Settings
and only, äh, ok, ich, ich bin da echt kein, ich hab echt keinen Plan, was Android Bedienung
angeht, so, und wie installiert man da Zertifikate, cert, install Zertifikat, install, da, trusted,
install, Zertifikat, CA, äh, eigentlich ein CA Zertifikat, oder, vermute ich mal, jawoll,
was ist das jetzt, nee, das Zertifikat musst du unter System ETC Security CA Zerts ballern,
aber in einem bestimmten Format, ok, kann man bestimmt mit Open SSL konvertieren, hat
das jetzt aber, vielleicht hat das ja so schon funktioniert, display trusted Zertifikat,
Zertifikates, ach nee, das ist, das ist jetzt ein User Zertifikat, das funktioniert jetzt
nicht, passt mal auf, äh, ich komm mit der Bedienung nicht klar, ich, ich kann jetzt,
geh mal auf google.de, das könnte funktionieren, der Browser, nee, siehst du, der mag auch
schon net, was weiß ich, heise.de, ok, der Browser hat schon ein bisschen, hat schon
gar keinen Bock mit dem, mit dem Zertifikat zu arbeiten hier, vielleicht muss ich noch
mal schließen, ja, irgendwas, nee, der mag mit dem Zertifikat gar nicht, kann man das
hier runterziehen, Alter, ich finde die Bedienung, da hat sich total viel geändert, oder, das
sieht komplett anders aus, anders als alte Android-Versionen, äh, mal hier weg, äh,
das Zertifikat funktioniert eh nicht, wie komm ich jetzt hier noch mal in die Apps rein,
so, boah, ist das eklig, Mensch, was, sign in, warum will, warum will auf einmal, dass
ich sign inne, Leute, ich will einfach nur in, ein Menü, install Zertifikat, ich will
das wieder, ich will das wieder löschen, trusted Zerts, user, das da, uninstall, weg,
ok, ok, also, chat, chat hat schon das Richtige gesagt, das klingt, das klingt sehr nachvollziehbar,
wo muss das, wo muss das hin, System, ETC, Security, CA Zerts, schauen wir mal, ob es
das überhaupt gibt, connect, ah ja, ok, das ist, ähm, zu Google, ADB Shell, ok, da liegt
ganz viel Zeug rum, ok, jetzt muss ich mal googeln, wie das funktioniert, also, mitem,
ach, Quatsch, muss man bestimmt irgendwie konvertieren, systems, ja, Android-Emulator,
ok, must not run a production build, ok, das haben wir ja, Proxy-Settings, haben wir gemacht,
mit dem Proxy CA Zertifikat has been recreated, können wir nachgucken, aber müsste es ja,
das hätte ich ja schlecht runterladen können, ja, ok, it's created, Rename-Certifikat, ok,
CA Zertifikats in Android are stored by the name of the hash with the, it is necessary
to configure, was, to figure out the hash of your CA Zertifikat, copy it to a file with
this hash as file name, Instructions, aha, Massive Sixhead Commands, da machen wir das
doch, so nice, wenn die da sogar schon eine Anleitung dabei haben, ja, zack, da ist es,
da ist Brauma, copy, insert certificate into system certificate store, now we have to place,
mouse it as read only, following steps, write permissions, what, was will das von, was wollen
die von mir, I gamble, Dankeschön, Vettel's, moin, ich hab dir grad geantwortet auf Twitter,
was, ja, this is read only, was muss ich denn jetzt machen überhaupt, Instruction for AP
Level, Instruction for, as root, ADB remount, no, ich, ich versteh auch nur Bahnhof, ok,
was, ADB root muss ich machen und dann remount, ne, das geht nicht, das heißt mein Android
ist zu neu, seh ich das richtig, list your emulators, das Kommando gibt's überhaupt
nicht, start design, ok, das haben wir doch grad schon gemacht, ADB root, disable secure
boot verification, Monk, guck mal hoch, hab's schon geschrieben, ok, Moment, Moment, Wischer,
für den Sub, wo hast du was geschrieben, ah, minus writable system, ah, ok, das heißt,
ich muss das ausmachen und in die settings wahrscheinlich, oder, ne, ne, erstmal ausmachen,
erstmal ausmachen, device manager, settings, und jetzt advanced settings, ne, wo, wo gab
ich denn das ein, wo stelle ich writable system ein in diesem komischen, boot options, ne,
wo stellt, wo stellt man das ein jetzt, über Konsole starten, boah, das ist aber high IQ
shit hier wieder, ok, über Konsole starten, Emulator, Emulator gibt's hier nicht, wo liegt
denn der Emu überhaupt, wie starte ich den überhaupt von Hand, das ganze Android Zeug
ist nervig, wo liegt denn das Teil hier überhaupt, liegt hier denn ein Emu, find, name, Emu, ne,
der Emulator gibt's hier gar nicht, boah, was ist das schon wieder für ein Gack, man,
ne, wo liegt der, ah, im SDK, oder wo ist das jetzt, wo hat der denn das hin, hat er
das im Home irgendwo, ah, guck mal, Android, ah, Android, find, ah, das sieht, das sieht
besser aus, hier SDK, SDK Emulator, ok, jetzt können wir nämlich das machen, was da oben
steht, Emulator List, nein, nein, nein, ok, ok, das ist gut, Start Designed Writable System,
also wahrscheinlich muss ich jetzt folgendes machen, so, oho, guck mal, da tut sich was,
ok, ok, ADB Root, ADB Shell, alles klar, ok, das müsste jetzt also funktionieren, also
wenn er gebootet hat, erstmal warten, bis er gebootet hat, das ist Kali, natürlich ist
das Kali, wenn wir so Zeug machen, müssen wir schon die echte Hacker-Man, alternativ
auch noch Tails verwenden können, wobei Tails eher für anonyme Anonymisierungskram und
anonyme Bewegungen im Internet gut ist, aber Kali ist, was gibt's denn sonst noch so,
mir fällt jetzt bloß Tails und Kali so aus dem Kopf ein, was gibt's denn noch für HiIQ
Distros in der Richtung, Parrot, Blackarch, ja, die gibt's, stimmt, ne, hab ich noch nie
was von gehört, keine Ahnung, Hannah Montana Linux, ja, das ist irgendein Ubuntu 14.04,
ok, also was, ADB Root, Restarting S-Root, ok, ADB Shellbla, aha, gucke mal da, ADB
Reboot, exzellent, exzellent, ADB Reboote das Ding jetzt, das ist, hab ich's jetzt kaputt
gemacht durch den Reboot oder, braucht es jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen, ah ne, ne,
es funktioniert, ok, alles gut, alles gut, nice, GG Eats, also, jetzt hab ich Reboot
gesagt, jetzt mach ich noch mal ADB Root, noch mal hinten drauf, alles klar, perform
Remount, ADB Remount, aha, das sieht gut aus, ADB Push Searchs, ok, also jetzt muss ich
das da, was hier liegt, was C8 irgendwas heißt, dahin kopieren, alles klar, ok, wie hieß
das nochmal, das Zertifikat, was ich kopiert hab, so, aha, und jetzt Reboot, ok, so, und
jetzt hab ich mein Man in the Middle Proxy Zertifikat als System CA Trusted installiert
oder wie, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt in den Settings in den Zertifikat Store gucke, in
den Trust Store gucke, dann sollte da irgendwas mit dem Proxy drinstehen, seh ich das richtig,
ja, ihr müsst jetzt ja eigentlich schon gleich was sehen hier, guck mal, guck mal, da tut
sich doch was schon, da tut sich doch schon was, da tut sich doch was, ok, boah, alter,
T-Mobile, das muss gleich ausgeschaltet werden, ne, hier Zerts, High Speed, alter Leute, High
Speed Emulation, WTF, Lack, Zert, ähm, hier war das, ne, Trusted Credentials System, so
und da sollte jetzt was mit Mitem drinstehen, wenn das alles funktioniert hat, ABCDEFGHIJKLM,
easy, easy, ok, heißt, ich kann jetzt HTTPS mitlesen, schauen wir mal, ups, das bräuchte
geil anklicken, wir machen mal das wieder zu, ok, Google, Internet is disconnected, Wi-Fi,
ah ja, Android Wi-Fi, ok, war aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht connected, jetzt macht der Dinger,
dann, ah guck mal, oh, guck mal, es läuft alles drüber, es läuft alles über ein Proxy,
Pog, ok, das wird ein kurzer Stream, Leute, heute glaube ich, wie krieg ich denn das wieder
zu, easy, easy, Pog, Pog in the middle, haben wir jetzt, Bergdoktorstaffel 16, Franziska,
ah ja, das interessiert mich auch unglaublich, aber guck mal, wir können jetzt den verschlüsselten
Traffic mitlesen, das ist sehr nice, Bergdoktorstaffel 16, Franziska, alles klar, gut, ja dann starten
wir mal die Fiat App und gucken, ob wir das mitkriegen, aha, ah, guck mal, da, da, da
ist es, da ist es, Coke hier, Query, Response, Encrypt oder Sachen, Massive, das ist ja cool,
schein zu funktionieren, gucken wir mal, wie ein Login aussieht, was nicht funktioniert,
was, share, ich will nicht shareen, Kekl, add, Kekl, Punkt Kekl, Moment, add, add geht
nicht, da solltet ihr mir jetzt ja eigentlich sagen, was lernt ihr denn überhaupt von mir,
so, da solltet ihr mir jetzt ja eigentlich sagen, dass es das nicht gibt, 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, Login, Login, config, ok, da können wir mal reingucken, Response, was,
iOS App Store, was willst du von mir Fiat, ich weiß, es sieht nicht aus wie ein iOS
Gerät, oder, ach, das war Pre-Login, ey, wo war ich denn hier jetzt überhaupt, wo war,
wo bin ich jetzt hier stehen geblieben, ich muss das mal kurz groß machen, Pre-Login,
hier, hier, Accounts Login, Invalid Login, all die, ok, nice, ich kann HTTPS traffic
von der App mitlesen, das ist sehr nice, einloggen kann ich mich jetzt hier nicht, weil ich mein
Passwort nicht leake im Stream, und ich kann mir einen Fake Account machen, das Problem
ist, ich sehe nicht da das, was ich sehen will, weil das, was ich sehen will, braucht man
ein registriertes Auto, das heißt, ich muss das gleiche jetzt nochmal machen, bei mir
in der VM, und dann meine Credentials eingeben, es sei denn, jemand gibt mir seine Credentials
und ich leake die jetzt live im Stream, dass die Leute, dass der Chat euer Auto fernsteuern
kann, das war jetzt aber tatsächlich ziemlich einfach, oder?
Da musst du ja gar nichts großartig für machen, das ist ja wirklich, also anders, anders, anders
kann man es nicht sagen, aber das ist easy.
Easy as fuck, get rekt, easy as fuck, easy, easy, easy, easy.
Ich find's immer seltsam, wenn 200 ok als Ergebnis bei einem Fehler kommt.
es ist ja kein webserver das ist eigentlich richtig so wie es ist
das ist ja kein webserver fehler sondern das ist irgendein anwendungsfehler
dann darf der webserver ruhig 200 antworten
ist bisschen geschmackssache viele missbrauchen die html statuscodes sowas
aber eigentlich ist das richtig
genau spannendes war sonst für requests gemacht werden aber das kann ich euch
nicht zeigen weil ich dafür einen account brauche und ich lock mich jetzt hier im
stream nicht ein das war wirklich easy ich weiß gar nicht was ich sagen soll
das will der von mir doch genug platz hat die app einen demo modus hat sie sehr
gute idee massive six hat das hat ein demo modus demo modus aber der ist rein
lokal der demo modus bis aussieht was natürlich ziemlich blöd ist ein lokal
demo modus bringt er nichts oder ich wäre mir jetzt gar nicht mal so sicher ob
das rein lokal ist carrier name t-mobile keck alles klar t-mobile was auch immer
ich da habe das sind aber nicht die normalen requests also das bringt mir
nix api
ne das sind nicht die normalen requests das ist fake fake requests haben wir
schleu ich kläre das mal alles machen das noch mal kurz zu und gucken das
noch mal neu an was eklig zu bedienen man
ne das sind nicht die normalen requests das ist tatsächlich das ist tatsächlich
alles lokal auch wenn sich so aussieht aber das anscheinend alles lokal hier
guck mal irgendwas wird wird nach italien geschickt nice gg hallo fiat
das steht ganz schön viel nach italien oder erst mal die device aldi ist das
überhaupt dsg v o konform dass der meine device aldi nach fiat zu fiat
schickt anzeige ist raus die weiß key alles klar
also was ich in meine in meine home assistance in mein home assistant einbauen
will ist das hier guck da hat man nämlich hier so einen kompletten lock
über seine farten natürlich nicht das grafisch ich will nur die daten haben
eco coaching response xml ist leeres xml poc nice ist ein leises xml ich hoffe
da kommt es nicht wirklich noch xml dabei too many requests ach ach nee wirklich fiat wirklich
hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht dass es too many requests sind dachte das ist
normal dass ihr abfragen müsst innerhalb von einer sekunde irgendwelche locks
ip resolved ip na gut das ist jetzt egal für mich ja gut was auch immer der da im
sekundentakt abfragt aber nix nix was man haben will wahrscheinlich ab ist aus ja
leute es funktioniert ich ich mehr will ich gar nicht wie er geht aus sich selber
ja schein mehr will ich gar nicht das heißt wir können jetzt was anderes machen im restlichen
stream null ich habe echt also ich habe jetzt nicht gedacht dass es so schnell geht ich weiß
wir gehen sie fertig das war tatsächlich ziemlich easy hätte ich nicht gedacht ich
meine ist das noch nicht mal 20 uhr ich könnte jetzt eigentlich entspannt noch ein bisschen
stream gucken und oft gehen oder wir gucken noch irgendwas zusammen können wir noch gucken
fünf gründe warum es die scharpe murks ist 30 min alter nein battlefield spiele ich jetzt
nicht
ich glaube das haben wir uns auf ich gehe jetzt wieder auf und gucke in ruhe ein bisschen
stream war halt mal kurz hätte genauso gut drei stunden dauern können bis der kram funktioniert
diesmal ging alles easy ohne probleme aber auch nur weil der freie chat mit geholfen hat
weißt du ob das für den fort pass ebenso möglich ist für die app ja das geht für
jede android app vielleicht musste die app noch repackagen wenn die da irgendwelche
anderen probleme machen aber das sollte potenziell mit jeder app funktionieren ich meine das
alleine bringt ja natürlich noch nichts du musst dann mit der ab mit den infos da drin
ja was anfangen können ja das war deutlich schneller als gedacht ok leute schön dass
ihr da gewesen seid ich gehe jetzt auf bis denn zu